they had like Mark Zuckerberg that Kevin
rose from speaking there's a lot of
great panels you have any interest in
any of that stuff at all I don't know
what you what you're talking about
you have to hear on Mark Zuckerberg I
know he is a great artist you haven't
heard it
do they have Ruby on Rails there how
many myspace friends do you have we're
hovering in about the 8500 range right
now oh you have like a start-up or
anything
startup yeah like a website oh yeah we
got myspace jko band there was a band
there you go demo versus demo these demo
it's online it's on facebook.com
okay Ruby on Rails I've no idea what
that is 85,000 8,500 oh oh did you hear
that they released the iPhone SDK I
don't know what that means
it's just others know you guys like PHP
or Ruby on Rails neither that's neither
how do you feel about PHP and Ruby on
Rails I feel really good feels really
good rock bands what level are you
no we're an indie right now
hard expert of funk rock reggae okay
like like the game rock bands you ever
play that oh don't play Nintendo me you
have to deal with scaling of the
infrastructure how would you deal with
that
I wouldn't I just chill scaling they you
know a lot of people start visiting your
site Oh
what do you mean how do we deal with it
yes awesome what are you talking about
MySpace
yeah Facebook yeah Twitter gets rid of
Twitter or pounce Twitter sooner Twitter
No are you on Digg there you go she's
thinking about getting a dig account
what he's talking about Mark Zuckerberg
who's that he's really good have you
heard him he's all country right
noise no more like tech okay to three
times a day now and yeah it's real fun
what do you all do it I don't know but
like do you think maybe I could get a
beta invite a what a beta invite beta
invite what is that like an invite do
you have a startup oh let's check this
out
do you how do you deal with scaling